so right now there's a guy he's 27 years
old
he let's say he went to school didn't
finish
okay he right now has a part-time job
making about
25 000 a year and he doesn't really have
much drive in life what is the first
step that you're going to tell that man
to do
nothing nothing
why does he not have drive in his life
so so let me give it to maybe from a
different perspective okay
um my dad kept telling me i'm lazy as a
kid
because i was i was bored half the time
class everything was boring to me so
eventually i go and i get a 1.8 gpa
i have a job at haagen-dazs and i worked
my ass off at night from 11 o'clock to
12 o'clock when everybody was asleep
i'd go grab a shopping cart and i would
go into trash cans and i would find two
liter bottles and cans and then i would
go to albertson and i would recycle so
every night i was making 10 bucks a
night
with my shopping cart that i had 10 or
20 my friend and i would split it he
would get half i would get up
and would collect him why are you guys
what are you guys doing because we
wanted to buy cards i wanted a sergey
fedorov rookie card i wanted a david
robinson 1989 hoops rookie card
so my motivation was what cards at the
time right okay
so later on when i sat there and i'm
like you know lazy man this topic keeps
coming up lazy lazy lazy why are people
lazy everything to me is linking a word
to another word when somebody says man
patrick
i'm the owner of 100 of this company
we're doing five million dollars here i
want to bring another guy in but
i just don't feel like i can control i
feel like i want to control everybody
i said can you tell me why you want to
control everybody why i said what word
links with control
the more you want to control somebody
the less you trust them
the less you want to control somebody
the more you trust them exactly
so you simply don't trust your people so
you got to figure out a way how much of
that is on you how much of that is on
them right okay that does kind of make
sense
you find somebody that's bitter why is
somebody bitter you're not part of a
community
and you're not creating anything new the
moment you no longer create
something of value to the world you
become bitter who's typically bitter
old man old people why are they bitter
because they're no longer contributing
you gotta figure right away to get them
to contribute to feel like
i am still needed in society the world
still needs me
wooden died at 99 john d rockefeller who
was born in 1835 said i'm gonna live a
hundred years
and i'm gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars he didn't make a hundred
thousand dollars in today's money he
made 340 billion dollars
do you know in 1835 the average life
expectancy for a man was 39 and a half
years old you know how long he lived
97 years and 11 months because he kept
contributing
okay so so when you look at this stuff
and like okay well here's what we got
going on how about this 27 year old kid
making 20 25 grand a year part-time job
and has no drive
he's bored out of his mind you either
need an enemy you need a vision
you need somebody to tell you can't do
something you need to put yourself in a
position where somebody slaps you around
that pisses you off and you wake up and
you're like wait a minute
what did you say yeah i'm gonna go out
there and go to war and show you that
i'm gonna do something big with my life
but that 25 year old is bored out of
their minds and quite frankly many times
there's nothing you can do about it
it has to come internal look life is a
test
you're being tested right now i don't
know how you're being tested right now
but somehow you're being tested it could
be personal life could be family could
be finance
it could be ego could be desires could
be advice no one knows but you're being
tested
i'm being tested she's being tested he's
being tested there's not a person right
now that's not being tested right
some of us don't pass the test who
controls that
you do that's not on you and i so that
25 year old that 27 year old
is being tested today and he's failing
today
because he has no desire to go out there
and do something he has to figure out a
way to self-motivate himself right now
there's nothing you and i can do at the
end of the day the individual has to
want to help themselves
we can't make miracles i can bring tony
robbins
joel osteen bring the biggest eric bring
the biggest motivational speakers in the
world
put them in a room of a thousand people
and you're still gonna have 80 percent
of people that are going to do nothing
when they leave that room
numbers are numbers that person's got to
want it themselves there's nothing you
can do about it
man so the first time i met you i
remember you came in the room
and there there was an energy shift in
the room when you walked into the room
and uh i only way i could describe it is
like this dragon energy it was like this
powerful being
and the more i began to read and to
learn it it's this sense of this
masculine energy that you exude
and one of the things that i've i was
reading about is this masculine energy
is this initiative it's just drive is
its passion
and and you can just feel it when
somebody walks in the room to
which i believe you said like in part of
your family crest is a lion did you
communicate that and that's what it
embodies right this fierce ferocious
competitor go-getter
and and you're 100 right for a lot of
these young men
they don't have that in them you know
they don't have it in them
and so i know you said there's nothing
that we can do about it but
have you seen anybody go from very
passive and lazy
and then awaken that inner line myself
okay myself
see the reason why i believe people
change is because i've witnessed my life
if you were to you know one of the
things i did a few years ago
i brought up my former sergeant from the
army
okay and i i put him on stage so i want
you to tell everybody a little bit about
who i was in the army and started
telling stories
i ended up bringing my sister into the
business with me she's one of our vice
presidents now paulo and siamak they
they do a great job they're one of the
vice presidents in the company
and i told everybody go ask my sister
anything you want to ask about how i was
and i said paulette
say whatever you want to say i'm good
and she would say pat was lazy pat was
this yeah no totally fine i
i'm okay then i brought another friend
who from the military
and people would ask him the questions
hey how was pat how was this how was dan
i don't have any problems with that then
i went and called one of my friends
called me one time i'll never forget his
name is adrian
and he said hey can we go out to lunch
and we went out to lunch this was even
12 years ago maybe 10 years ago maybe
even before like i was
online anything and he says pat can i
tell you something i said yeah
at the time i'm probably making quarter
million to a half a million dollars when
him and i are having this conversation
my late 20s
he says i'm going to tell you something
that most of your friends are not going
to tell you so what's that adrian
he says pat i never thought you were
going to make it i'm not one of these
guys that's going to tell you i know pat
was going to make us pat i never thought
you were going to make it yeah i never
thought you could know anything with
your life when you went into the army i
thought that was it like you're gonna go
make 38 grand 40 grand and that's
it he says i am shocked at who you
became okay perfect
so now flip it you ask me the question
with this 25 year old
i'm telling you i don't have any fire i
don't have any fire
one day uh i'm at
ucla medical center in la
my dad has a heart attack you've heard
me tell this story before my dad has a
heart attack and you know my dad is like
my dad's at this time i'm partying five
six days a week i'm in vegas every other
weekend
so i go to the hospital and i see him
and i see him laying in bed and the
nurse is calling the nurse not showing
up the
nurse gave him a little bit of an
attitude and that's when i lost it i'm
calling out the nurse just acting fully
irresponsible at the house my dad is
panicking patrick please calm down
please come down and he just had a heart
attack just
foolish absolutely there's nothing about
my behavior that was acceptable
except the fact that i wanted my debt to
get better service right
so eventually they kick me out i get
kicked out of the hospital i can't go
visit my dad they kick me out of the
hospital
and you know i get in my car ford focus
and i sit there and i cry for 30
straight minutes okay the next day
i told my friends never ever call me
again to go to clubs
pat come on man what are you talking
about i said don't ever call me again
i'm not going
you're not gonna see me at the clubs
anymore i'm not gonna party with you
i'm not gonna go to clubs with you pat
you're out of your mind there's no way
in the world
you can't stop we all know who you are
because i was great at the party inside
you will never stop i said okay i'm just
telling you don't call me anymore
so they started calling me one month two
months
three months six months guess what
happened never went to the clubs ever
again
that night decision was made the old pat
died i killed the old pat
give you another part of the story here
one day
i'm sitting there i'm like why do i
drink i don't know why i'm drinking
done with alcohol i dropped alcohol and
i stopped drinking now this is coming
from a guy that every weekend in the
army i would drink two bottles of
tequila
when i would go to the clubs we would
drive from kentucky all the way up to
nashville tennessee
makes factory connections silverados all
this stuff
and by the time we got there we're
hammered if you see most of my military
pictures in nashville
if there's any military picture you see
out of my album in nashville i am
hammered and you'll see it on the look
of my face to all of a sudden saying
dude i'm done okay and to me saying
no sex for 17 months until i make my
money
i made some drastic decisions who can't
do that they can do that
you control the choice see the reason
why capitalism is a beautiful thing
is because of four things you have the
freedom to buy whatever you want to buy
that's legal
you have the freedom to sell whatever
you want to sell that's legal
you have the freedom to try whatever you
want you don't want to do real estate
try insurance you don't want to do
insurance try digital market you don't
want to go try youtube you can try
anything you want
but you know what the last one is the
freedom to fail
we don't give enough credit to this the
reason why certain people in the
world are respected and admired at the
level that they are
is because so many people fail because
when the pressure hits
most people leave the arena we all root
for the people in the arena and we
criticize them
what we don't recognize is the fact that
whoever is in the arena getting their
asses handed to them
at least they had the courage to get in
the arena they're not fans on the
outside
they're in the arena fighting those are
the people we admire so
these young guys that you're talking
about pat you know a lot of people don't
have the drive
i wish you knew me in your in my early
20s you would have more confidence on
people being able to shift because
i had to choose one thing happened next
thing i'm a whole different person
[Music]